One important aspect of any research study is something called the Effect Size.
In experimental studies, or studies with a treatment variable, effect size
refers to the size of a treatment effect. Makes intuitive sense. In non
experimental studies. The term effect size may refer to the strength of the
relationship between our variables. In the Z-test or in the t-test, the
simplest measure effect size is the mean difference which is simply the
difference between the two means. In the Z-test or the one sample t-test, the
mean difference is x bar minus mu. Mean differences are great when we have
variables with easy to understand meanings. In other words, those that we can
understand without any specialized training.